so we're gonna start with the revenant
well first of all I had to make an L a
boy look like a trapper he's meant to
have been out in the wilderness for over
a year when we come across him and
Alejandra really wanted Leo to look aged
so I did a bit of aging I gray grade his
beard every day which meant painting
individual hairs and into his beard that
took 20 minutes alone and then I had to
break down his skin texture add some
scars Nicks and cuts to his hands and
then you get to the bear attack where
basically the whole of his body gets
covered in injuries and wounds I start I
got I started prepping in April 2014 and
I wrapped in August 2015 it was a long
long job and there was a lot of prep
involved they were just for the neck
itself there were seven different stages
sometimes there were up to four of us
working on him and it took up to four
and a half hours for the full body for
that scene he had 47 pieces on the all
hat who painted on the day because they
were all transfer molds onto his body so
there's 47 wounds for that kind of that
see how that was the longest make of
that look took four and a half to five
hours when you first receive he's
waiting for the revenant do you break
each scene down and design it you know
you read the script you see which
characters are playing and and what they
go through to get to certain scenes and
accordingly so every character will have
his own locker particular evolution of a
particular look to a particular scene
and you just of course it all changes
throughout the filming of it with the
director and the way he evolves
throughout it but generally yeah so
reading the script breaking down
characters scenes and progression
they've been out in this wilderness for
a number of months and obviously they're
tired and fatigued and how do you work
to kind of create an aesthetic that
seems more and more worn as the film
goes on you know trying to put yourself
in the heads of the particular people
that are in the film as the characters
how long were they there what did they
go through to try to think about
was done I remember one of our coldest
days being well into the minus 30s and
so to try to achieve the look for them
there you know I would look when it was
that cold how long they've been out
there
Alejandra wanted you to have separate
stories for each of the traffic Andra
wanted to have backstories to every
trapper why their hair was the way it
was he said we might never ever see that
particular scar or that particular bit
of hair missing but he said we'll know
that it's there and he just wanted to
know everything so every every character
had had their own story and it was a lot
of fun and it helped me along with my
job as well to understand where they
were why they were would you have like a
couple of key pieces kind of kit or
makeup that you could not have lived
without why I ended up using a lot on on
this day strohman Pass Fleet Street it's
blood they were fantastic the colors are
so good and also a protocol psoriasis
which I wasn't expecting to use on this
film it was really good for starting off
the weathering and for blending in the
lip pieces with the lips and it just so
basically broke down the skin texture so
every job I think you find something
that is perfect for that film and then
you add it to your arsenal of wonder
products as you go along how did the
weather affect the makeup on this well
our prostate kept freezing and we had to
take certain products home with us at
night to make sure they didn't freeze on
the trailer cause one day we got into
the trailer and all our bags had frozen
to the floor I had to do makeup in a hat
and a coat and it was wrapped in a
blanket because it was so cold because
our trailer had come from Vancouver and
it wasn't designed really for the
weather in Calgary so you know did the
the biggest problem for us there was
maintaining makeup on set because you
think you know you've got hand
prosthetics on you want to make sure
they look good but at the end of the day
if your actor's gonna get frostbite you
can't be worrying about whether the
prosthetic is hanging off the priority
is to get his hands in the warm
hairdryer that are going to distress
that makeup even more but that has to be
a priority safety on a film like this is
paramount you have to take a back seat
with the makeup maintenance and
just be thinking about the safety
reactor a lot of the time thank you
so with the Danish girl it's obviously
based on a true story and the
transformation of Einar
to Lily what were your initial reference
point he was actually a middle aged
woman by the time he became Lili
but the the whole premise of the story
was really about Gerdes vision of Lily
because Gerda painted Lily and so Tom
would always keep saying look at the
paintings look at the paintings and what
was so lovely about that is all the
paintings would be at very 1920s she
painted Lily with wonderful dark hair
and red hair which is we ended up using
in the end so my reference points were
all those colors and also the production
designer Eve had already started so a
color palette was already there we had
wonderful cool colors in Copenhagen and
then when we went to Paris all the
colors warmed up so when I first tested
with AD because we were very concerned
about how much he was going to look like
a woman I tested the colours that were
in the paintings and of course Eddie
looked great with dark hair and he
looked even better with the red hair
which is the one that one through it's
funny when I work with Eddie before on
theory there was always one side of his
face that looked more masculine and we
seemed to shoot on that side and for
sure it was the other side that was much
more feminine so that's how we based it
so that's why we were always showing his
left-hand side because it just
proportion wise if you you know when the
camera shooting one way and the other
way he just looked more feminine so we
we used that of course and also angles
and everything were really important and
as the film progresses and he becomes
more feminine all the way through
I imagine each one of those changes for
you must have been quite a big change in
terms of makeup I mean every film we all
do we break our scripts down so I
already knew the continuity of the film
of every character it's all broken down
on you write all your notes out and you
shoot out of order but what I really
wanted to do with Eddie's character in
particular is that each time I not
dressed as Lili and then
address back assign our I wanted to make
sure that I and I became more feminine
each time it was like not being able to
deny Lily's presence because you know
Lily was really who she was he was in
the beginning when I made up Eddie as I
know I made him much more masculine I
hardened up his face a bit I did a lot
more highlighting and shading made his
face just a little bit stronger you know
strengthened his eyebrows he wore wigs
all the way through he had a wig on when
he was I not because his own hair is too
short to look 1920s so each time I just
softened that masculine look and just
made it more and more feminine you know
I go to Brooklyn there how did you
create hell up for Ireland I just kept
it very plain and simple tiny bit of
mascara lip sells and it's very small
business foundation I keep it very very
light because there were huge close-ups
on her in HD which was terrifying
Brooklyn and obviously it becomes a
woman in a way it has her own
independent you how do you subtly change
I suppose the makeup was just to sort of
map her internal emotions and how she
changed so I think her makeup changed
when she met this Italian boy at a dance
and her friends brought her into the
toilet and put lipstick on and then she
took it from there but it was always a
quiet she wasn't a big fashion icon it
was very quiet you know sort of quite
sophistication really in terms of her
hair obviously when you see here in
Ireland it's very pull back and very
simple our director and John he wanted
just a little bit more Irish and sir
she's naturally blond so warmed up her
hair with a little red and then simple
curls and then when she went to New York
just slowly took a little influence from
Grace Kelly
look little sophistication and tried to
certainly turn her into a swan as she
became more confident a little bit more
sophistication when she was working in
the New York store and she meets the
Italian boy and then goes back to
Ireland and everybody in Ireland sees a
big change in her and just very subtle
really
you know with Carol me it seemed there
was a perfect marriage between the hair
and makeup in the costume I was
particularly responsible for Cate
Blanchett's but the costume designer was
Sandy Powell and actually we did our
first film together in the 1980s which
was Caravaggio so it was really nice I
mean speaking about the character of
Carol you know we chose to go with all
the coral colors you know sandy did such
exquisite costumes that with grey with
flashes of coral so I always used soft
coral lips and nails and of course cows
are very sophisticated put together a
character so it was a very chic
fashionable look of 1952 in New York
Rooney's character was more of a
discovery character so at the beginning
a bit like Brooklyn really she's working
in a department store and she's very
much more a girl and who hasn't
discovered herself yet and so she had a
less complete loop she didn't really
wear much makeup and she was still
finding herself
I suppose final question what are the
best and the worst parts of the job the
worst part is looking your kit this is
one of the best bits well I would like
to thank Robert Sean genetics and thank
you all for coming George kept bringing
wind machines in closer and closer until
all the wigs were being blown off is
that why Charlize Theron didn't have
anything so that that then became a
combination from Margaret sixel our
editor to put it all together and the
storyboard made sure that what the
action unit got and we got it was
comparable and compatible
you